190.000 neuinfektionen ca aktuell die
inzidenz wieder weit über 1000 zoff
zwischen den beiden gibt es aber wegen
der schlechten kommunikation in sachen
genesenen status ja wie lafer kürze den
jahr über nacht von sechs auf drei
monate laut lauterbach ohne dessen
wissen die verantwortung muss er
trotzdem tragen denn das rk ii ist im
jahr unterstellt und er informierte die
gesundheitsminister der länder nichts
jetzt versuchen beide gute miene zum
schlechten spiel zu machen
rks professor doktor lothar wieler und
gesundheitsminister professor doktor
karl lauterbach beide mediziner beide
vereint im kampf gegen korona ich mache
nämlich meine arbeit und die ist
wissenschaftlich fundiert in erster
linie man könnte fast meinen sie seien
freunde doch manchmal hapert es an der
kommunikation
hier war es so dass sie mich nicht mehr
erreicht hatten vor der eigentlichen
sitzung also ich hab das so in
erinnerung dass unsere empfehlung vor
dem beschluss der mpk auf der website
werden als lauterbach noch bloßer
abgeordneter war und nicht teil des
kabinetts konnte er gemeinsam mit wieder
lautstark noch sparen kritisieren und
immer mehr maßnahmen fordern kaum ist
der selbst den amt merkt er ganz so
einfach ist es nicht aber wie sagt man
so schön lass uns freunde bleiben
sonst nicht
ja und mal abgesehen vom
kommunikationschaos wird der sinn der
verkürzung des genesenen status auf drei
monate von wissenschaftlern übrigens
auch bezweifelt und in europa steht
deutschland damit auch allein auf weiter
flur die eu hat vor kurzem nämlich sechs
monate festgelegt was glaubst du wie es
in anderen ländern aus nicht
bestimmt nicht so schlecht wie bei uns
oder auf
die karte schauen meine damen und herren
und dabei immer im hinterkopf behalten
dass das virus ja überall dasselbe ist
egal ob wir in kuba für sich ob wir in
in deutschland sind oder beispielsweise
sagen wir mal in der schweiz da gilt der
genesenden status neun monate wir
schauen mal hier auf die niederlande da
gilt er zwölf monate also in blau
eingefärbt die eu konformen länder da
haben wir frankreich beispielsweise
dabei polen dabei österreich dabei
tschechien dabei belgien luxemburg
überall dasselbe nur in deutschland ist
der status auf drei monate verkürzt
worden ich verrecke mich gerade hier so
ein bisschen und wo ich gerade hier
schon stehe schauen wir auf die aktuelle
infektions lage ich ausholen schon
angedeutet 190.000
148 neuinfektionen gemeldet binnen 24
stunden
gestern waren es über 200.000 also ein
leichter rückgang wir schauen auch noch
auf die viel wichtigere
hospitalisierung since it ends da sehen
wir hier das wir eigentlich überall noch
im gelben bereich sind außer oben in
norddeutschland und in bremen zwischen
drei und sechs incidence bedeutet zweig
status nach den festlegungen die gemacht
worden sind wobei man dazu sagen muss
wir den hier nicht über
intensivstationen belegen sondern
überhaupt über die hospitalisierung
instanz also menschen die in
krankenhäusern sind auf die hotspots
können wir auch noch mal schauen da
sehen wir dass die karte im prinzip
unverändert geblieben ist wir haben eben
eher werte über 1000 in zahlreichen
gebieten in deutschland die
hospitalisierung instanz also aber noch
mal der hinweis ist der entscheidende
faktor so und wie schon gesagt gleich
beginnt in wenigen minuten die
pressekonferenz
lothar wieler karl lauterbach sitzen da
mal wieder zusammen alles vor dem
hintergrund den wir vorher besprochen
haben und steigen wir eine dieses thema
sandra du hast philippiak of der jetzt
schnell sein handy weg legen müssen an
deiner seite
so sieht's aus vielen dank thomas ja
philipp schoneville ávila diese
wortspiele sie prasse nur dahin warum
hat er das so entschied mit dem
genesenen status für uns drei monate eu
weit sind wir wirklich ganz allein auf
weiter flur
lka chef lothar wieler schweigt seit
diese entscheidung heute bei der
pressekonferenz wird er das zum ersten
mal kommentieren ich erinnere daran
diese entscheidung wurde überraschend
über nacht vom 14 auf den 15 januar
getroffen das heißt es gebe eigentlich
für ihre sehr genug zeit gewesen um sich
zu äußern aber lothar wieler hat sich
entschlossen zu schweigen bis heute
warum hat er das so entschieden ich habe
das lka gestern angefragt und wollte
wissen was war die wissenschaftliche
begründung und was da zurückkamen hat
mich doch schon sehr überrascht ein
zentraler satz war wir haben aktuell gar
keine daten dazu wie sich das verhältnis
genesenen also mit genesene die eine
omikron infektion durch machen man weiß
nicht wie lange sie geschützt sind und
wie gut sie geschützt vor einer
zweitinfektion das hat mich dann doch
überrascht ich habe mich gefragt na ja
wenn ihr keine daten habt warum habt ihr
dann die entscheidung so getroffen und
er verweist man auf zwei britische
untersuchung deren ergebnisse darauf
hindeuten dass der schutz nach einer
infektion abnimmt und zwar schneller als
bei einer delta infektion was aber auch
interessant war man hat gleichzeitig mir
mitgeteilt aus dem robert koch institut
das auch der schutz bei doppelt
geimpften stark abnimmt also nach der
zweiten impfung nach zwei oder drei
monaten ist der schutz vor einer
weiteren infektion bei unter 20 prozent
und damit niedriger als der von
genesenen und trotzdem gilt der
genesenen status jetzt in deutschland
drei monate und der geben status neun
monate also was das lka gestern erklärt
hat hat ehrlich gesagt nur noch mehr
fragen aufgeworfen könnte es sein dass
er heute das ganze wieder rückgängig
macht und doch wieder auf sechs monate
geht also ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt
schwer vorstellen dass man sich so
wirklich die blamage eingesteht und es
ist eine blamage wir haben gerade über
die europäische karte geschaut das ist
ja nicht so dass deutschland etwas
besser weiß im gegenteil deutschland
weiß ganz viele dinge schlecht das
erklärt mir gesagt wir haben keine daten
ich glaube er steht unter ganz großen
druck und er muss diese entscheidung
heute wirklich gut erklären weil sehr
prominente wissenschaftler sich dagegen
ausgesprochen haben carsten watzl der
immunologe hat gesagt das macht keinen
sinn hendrik strikt hat gestern der bild
zeitung gesagt
es macht keinen sinn genesen schlechter
zu stellen als geimpfte und wenn solche
top wissenschaftler sich äußern dann
muss auch der lkw show wirklich gute
gründe finden für seine entscheidung und
es ist nicht das erste mal dass er mehr
fragen als antworten aufwirft meint das
ist wirklich nicht das erste mal denken
wir allein an die vergangenen wochen
zurück anfang dezember sagte lothar
wieler voraus dass in einigen wochen
eine überlastung ermöglicht der
intensivstation zu befürchten sei er
sagte voraus dass die zahlen stark
steigen werden kurz nach seiner prognose
nur wenige tage später begann die zahl
der intensivbetten der belegten betten
zu sinken dann kam das nächste große
vorbei der expertenrat
verabschiedete eine stellungnahme kurz
vor der einer
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz lothar
wieler der auch dem expertenrat angehört
zeichnete sie mit und dann am tag der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
veröffentlichte er sein eigenes papier
überrumpelte karl lauterbach
überrumpelte den bundeskanzler olaf
scholz und wurde auch von beiden
wirklich sehr heftig kritisiert dann
erinnern wir uns an den wochenlangen
daten blindflug den uns auf den ehrlich
gesagt auch das robert-koch-institut
verantwortet wir wussten wochenlang
nicht wie viele infektionen wir in
deutschland haben aber danach haben sich
die maßnahmen gerichtet und nach das ist
das ist die schuld des robert koch
instituts und da wirklich passieren so
viele fallen so viele pannen den
vergangenen wochen dass man sich fragt
wie lange will lauterbach sich das
eigentlich noch anschauen wie lange
also wir wissen dass das verhältnis
angespannt ist das verhältnis war auch
schon ehrlich gesagt unter
gesundheitsminister jens spahn sehr
angespannt das kam daher dass lothar
wieler gerne mal selbst zum handy griff
und die bundeskanzlerin angerufen hat um
sie über die neuesten kroner
informationen zu informieren allerdings
ist sein direkter vorgesetzter
eigentlich sparen und der war natürlich
nicht allzu glücklich damit es ist aber
nun so karl lauterbach war zwar
überrumpelt von dieser entscheidung hat
gestern in der frankfurter allgemeinen
zeitung gesagt ich wollte nicht
informiert dass das lka den genesenen
status so plötzlich über nacht kürzen
will allerdings stellte sich hinter
diese entscheidung und sagte
wissenschaftlich ist sie richtig und
damit macht er sich zu eigen ja lothar
wieler hat ihm diese diese eingebracht
er hat es die bislang schwerste krise
eingebrockt in der lauterbach steckt
aber ich glaube lauterbach will ihn
nicht so schnell gehen lassen weil dann
richtet sich die kritik natürlich auf
ihn